>>> LAWMAKERS INVESTIGATING THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION FACE A
ROADBLOCK OF SORTS IN AN EFFORTS
TO GET A FORMER ALLY OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ALLIES TO
TESTIFY, MORE THAN A WEEK AFTER
SUBPOENAING FORMER TRUMP AIDE
DAN SCAVINO, THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
PHYSICALLY SERVE THAT SUBPOENA.
THEY CAN'T FIND HIM.
>> WHICH IS REMARKABLE.
SUBPOENAS -- THE SUBPOENA HAS A
DEADLINE OF TOMORROW TO COMPLY
FOR DOCUMENTS.
SO THERE IS A QUESTION OF HOW
DOES THIS IMPACT THE COMMITTEE
AND ALSO IT IS JUST SORT OF
LEAVES YOU SCRATCHING YOUR HEAD,
THEY CAN'T FIND DAN SCAVINO?
>> WHERE IN THE WORLD IS DAN
SCAVINO.
THE TIMELINE IS IMPACTED A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE AS YOU
MENTIONED THE DEADLINE FOR
DOCUMENTS IS TOMORROW.
HOWEVER, THE DEADLINE FOR
DEPOSITIONS IS NOT FOR ANOTHER
NINE DAYS .
THERE IS A LOT OF TIME TO BRING
HIM IN AND DEPOSE HIM.
SO THE TIMELINE WHILE NOT IDEAL
FOR HOUSE INVESTIGATORS IS NOT
STRETCHED TOO FAR AT THIS POINT.
IF WE GET TO OCTOBER 14th AND
STILL CAN'T FIND HIM, THAT'S GO
TO BE A BIGGER PROBLEM FOR THEM.
THE INDICATION IS THAT MANY
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED
ARE PLANNING TO COMPLY.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE WHO WERE
PART OF THE RALLY ORGANIZATION,
FOR EXAMPLE, SOURCES TELLING US
THAT THEY PLAN TO COMPLY.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE SUPERVISOR,
HEAD OF SECURITY THAT DAY, THE
PRIVATE SECURITY FOR THE EVENT,
PLANS TO COMPLY AS WELL.
OTHER PEOPLE ARE OUT THERE
TAKING THIS VERY SERIOUSLY.
JUST AN INABILITY TO NAIL DOWN
WHERE DAN SCAVINO'S PHYSICAL
BODY IN THIS MOMENT, TO ACTUALLY
HAND HIM THE PAPERS, WHICH IS --
YOU MENTIONED THIS IS KIND OF
BAFFLING.
OTHER PEOPLE SEEM TO HAVE
RECEIVED THESE.
>> AND UBIQUITOUS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA, CAN'T FIND HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING ME TO DISCUSS IS
AMBASSADOR NORM EISEN, FORMER
HOUSE JUDICIARY SPECIAL COUNSEL
AND FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
FIRST IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AND
RICHARD PAINER, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE ETHICS LAWYER.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU TO BOTH OF
YOU HERE.
I WONDER WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
SCAVINO CASE, ARE YOU CONCERNED
THAT FOLKS INVOLVED IN THIS CAN
STONE WALL THE INVESTIGATION,
RIGHT, DELAY, HIDE, NOT TESTIFY
IMMEDIATELY, CHALLENGE IN COURT,
START WITH YOU, NORM.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
HERE.
>> JIM, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK ON THE PROGRAM.
THEY CAN RUN, BUT THEY CANNOT
HIDE.
THIS IS NOT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHERE THE
PRESIDENT COULD EMBARK ON A
STONE WALLING CAMPAIGN BACKED BY
BOGUS CLAIMS OF EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, AND THEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT WOULDN'T ENFORCE
THE LAW CREATING IMPUNITY FOR
THOSE FOUR YEARS, JIM.
HERE YOU'RE GOING TO -- YOU HAVE
STRONG PRECEDENCE THAT WE HELPED
ESTABLISH IN THE McGANN CASE FOR
TESTIMONY.
AND IN THE MAZERS CASE FOR
DOCUMENTS, THOSE ARE GOING TO BE
ENFORCED BY CONGRESS AND DOJ
WILL WEIGH IN AS WELL.
SO, NO, THEY CANNOT STALL LIKE
THEY DID UNDER TRUMP.
>> AND WE SHOULD NOTE TO FOLKS
WHO ARE WATCHING, NORM, YOU
SERVED UNDER DEMOCRATS.
RICHARD, YOU SERVED UNDER
REPUBLICANS AND YOU'RE PART OF A
BIPARTISAN GROUP, FORMER JUDGES
AND LAWYERS WHO ARE ZEROING IN
ON THIS MEMO BY THE PRO-TRUMP
ATTORNEY JOHN EASTMAN WHICH LAID
OUT AN ACTION PLAN, FOR HOW THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP MIGHT OVERTURN
THE ELECTION, WITH THE HELP OF
THEN VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE.
IN YOUR LETTER TO THE CALIFORNIA
BAR, YOU SAY THE AVAILABLE
EVIDENCE SUPPORTS A STRONG CASE
THAT THE STATE BAR SHOULD
INVESTIGATE WHETHER IN THE
COURSE OF REPRESENTING MR. TRUMP
MR. EASTMAN VIOLATED HIS ETHICAL
OBLIGATIONS AS AN ATTORNEY BY
FILING FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS,
ENGAGING IN DECEPTIVE CONTACT.
HE WOULD GET KICKED OUT OF THE
BAR THERE.
BUT IS THAT -- IS THAT THE MOST
WE CAN HELP IN -- HOPE IN TERMS
OF LEGAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
SOMEONE LIKE EASTMAN, GIVEN WHAT
HE WAS TRYING TO DO HERE?
>> I HOPE NOT.
I HAVE REPEATEDLY URGED THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE APPOINT A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE THE EVENTS AFTER THE
ELECTION LEADING UP TO JANUARY
6th.
AND THAT INCLUDES AN
INVESTIGATION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP, PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
LAWYERS, MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
AND SENATE, AND WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS INVOLVED WITH THE
INSURRECTION AND SEDITION OF
JANUARY 6th.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND NEEDS
TO APPOINT A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR.
BUT UNTIL THEN, WE WILL DO WHAT
WE CAN TO HOLD THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THESE EVENTS
RESPONSIBLE.
WE KNOW WHAT DONALD TRUMP
WANTED.
HE WANTED TO PRESSURE THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO REVERSE THE ELECTION RESULTS,
INCITED A CROWD OUTSIDE THE
CAPITOL, AND NOW WE SEE DONALD
TRUMP'S LAWYER DRAFTING A MEMO
THAT IT SEEMS THE AIM AT THE
SAME RESULT, AND I WORKED FOR
MANY YEARS ON THE ISSUE OF WHEN
LAWYERS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR CLIENTS' CONDUCT, MY FIRST
LAW REVIEW ARTICLE WAS ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LAWYERS FOR
CLIENT CONDUCT, I BELIEVE MR.
EASTMAN CROSSED THE LINE.
THAT'S SOMETHING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BAR TO INVESTIGATE
AND THE FACTS ARE SET FORTH IN
OUR COMPLAINT.
>> I MEAN, HE'S ONE PIECE, A BIG
PIECE OF WHAT APPEARS TO BE A
LARGER PLOT HERE.
WE'RE NINE MONTHS OUT FROM
JANUARY 6th.
AND YOU HAVE A NUMBER THAT FOLKS
ARE STORMING THE CAPITOL HAVE
LEGAL CONSEQUENCES BUT NOT THE
RING LEADERS, RIGHT?
I WONDER ARE WE EXPOSING HERE
THAT THE SYSTEM IS NOT UP TO THE
TASK OF POLICING THIS?
BY THE WAY, MEANWHILE, DONALD
TRUMP IS, AGAIN, THE PUNITIVE
NOMINEE FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
IN 2024.
>> WELL, JIM, TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE SYSTEM IS UP TO THE TASK OF
PROTECTING OUR ELECTIONS AND
PROTECTING OUR DEMOCRACY IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY, AS YOU SEE WITH
ME AND RICHARD, THAT'S WHY WE
CAME TOGETHER IN THIS STATES
UNITED DEMOCRACY CENTER THAT
ORGANIZED AND FILED THIS BAR
COMPLAINT AGAINST EASTMAN AND
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WE'RE WORKING TO SHORE UP BY
PUSHING BACK ON SHAM AUDITS, BY
LITIGATING AGAINST THESE
TERRIBLE VOTER HIJACK BILLS THAT
ARE IN THE STATES, JIM.
OUR STATES UNITED DEMOCRACY
CENTER WORKING TOGETHER,
CO-CHAIRS, REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
CHRISTIE TODD WHITMAN, THESE ARE
NOT PARTISAN ISSUES.
OUR DEMOCRACY IS UNDER ASSAULT
BECAUSE OUR ELECTIONS ARE UNDER
ASSAULT.
AND STARTING WITH THE EASTMAN
COMPLAINT AND MUCH, MUCH MORE
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> RICHARD PAINTER, BEFORE WE
GO, ARE ANY OF THE SENIOR
OFFICIALS, INCLUDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, BUT OTHERS WHO HELPED
AND AIDED THIS PLOT, GOING TO
FACE CHARGES FOR THIS, RIGHT?
OR WILL IT BE ANOTHER INSTANCE
OF A LOT OF SOUND AND FURY BUT
NO ACTUAL ACTION?
>> WELL, THE PROSECUTOR DOWN IN
ATLANTA IS LOOKING AT STATE
CHARGES AGAINST DONALD TRUMP, I
BELIEVE, FOR SOLICITATION OF
ELECTION FRAUD.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE DOES NEED TO APPOINT
A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND THOSE WORKING FOR HIM.
I WILL NOTE I WAS A REPUBLICAN
FOR 30 YEARS, AND ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ACCOMPLISHMENTS
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS THE
14th AMENDMENT OF THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION, SECTION 3
OF THE 14th AMENDMENT
DISQUALIFIES FROM PUBLIC OFFICE
ANYONE WHO HAS SUPPORTED AN
INSURRECTION SUCH AS WHAT
HAPPENED DURING JANUARY 6th AT
THE CAPITOL, JANUARY 6th.
DONALD TRUMP IS DISQUALIFIED
FROM PUBLIC OFFICE UNDER SECTION
3 OF THE 14th AMENDMENT, AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT NEEDS TO
APPOINT A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR TO
PROSECUTE EVERYONE INVOLVED IN